um
oh
okay so this
all right
oh
um
today
at least
um
younger brothers
um
is
you're gonna be there
no i'm not okay
uh
oh so this is finally off okay
oh
oh yeah
i mean really can he do it
so i should go there
so rick scott man yeah
what actually makes me nervous about
that is you know he
was exposed a week ago and has had that
you know knows
all these negative tests in between yeah
i think my wife told me she had rapid he
had rapid
not pcr oh really
no look if you get one every day then
you're probably talking about
it
i was very impressed with the system
here having done it yesterday
very good yeah
uh
uh
fools
right
oh
uh
will they do a two minute warning
they made it
seriously
i mean the sun works in the white house
monday will be worse
oh
everybody
is
yes
in the back of the yeah
oh really
it takes three to five
thank you
giuliani's
i mean basically no one cares if we died
absolutely
i can't give you guys
um
is
good morning everyone
as our nation prepares for thanksgiving
we just thank god for all the blessings
he has bestowed upon us
our men and women in uniform who keep us
safe
we thank them and their families for the
sacrifices they make
for our democracy for our freedom
this year we won't be able to be joining
each other
in the traditional way but virtually
we'll come together to thank god for our
blessings
as we do so though it will be with great
pain
have lost their lives to the coronavirus
daily cases have averaged over 160 000
in this past week hospitalizations have
set a national
record for three days in a row last week
and over
11 million it's 11.7 million and growing
have been people have been infected
cases
are said to rise the economic front
20 million americans are on unemployment
with the benefit expire
and millions have fallen into poverty
and are food insecure and face the
threat
of addiction so this is what is in our
hearts
sadly our traditional some of the things
that we do regularly but especially at
thanksgiving
to minister to those who are forward and
secure in the rest
will not actually be pop possible
but nonetheless we must try
we are in a full-blown economic and
health
catastrophe and it's amazing to see the
patients the gop
has for other people's suffering
in another week a few weeks will observe
the eighth anniversary
of sandy hook eight years ago we saw the
unspeakable horror
of innocent children being gunned down
at sandy hook
the people cried out for gun violence
prevention
but the republicans just brushed it off
this too shall pass several months ago
we all watched the murder of george
floyd
the american people poured into the
streets in fact people all over the
world
poured on into the streets for days and
in some cases weeks but republicans
ignored that refused to pass legislation
this too shall pass now 250 000
americans as i mentioned
are dead the numbers rising
over six months ago when we passed the
heroes act
leader mcconnell said we need a pause
we need a pause well i would hope
that for him the pause can come
to an end
nearly 200 000 people have died during
that pause
so we're asking him come back to the
table
a few days ago leader um schumer and i
sent him this a letter which you've all
seen asking the republicans to come back
to the table
to meet the needs of the american people
which they have been willing
to ignore we would like to extend
some of the provisions of the cares act
which are set to expire the end of this
year
we want to again add to that meeting the
food needs every 17 million children in
america
are food insecure and we have a hard
time getting to put food
addressing those food needs into
legislation
we must have that the american people
want that that's part of our value
system
again let's have help with rental
assistance
okay have a have a a moratorium but
unless the rent is paid people are not
going to be able to stay in their homes
and their landlords they're not going to
be able uh to pay the bank
so this helps everybody it has become
clear in the past six months
that we needed more ppp to help our
small businesses
let's work that in as we have we have
tightened our belt any number of times
in our heroes act and once again uh a
months ago to
include ppp the list goes on and on
but some of these things about
unemployment insurance food security
stopping evictions
to keep our businesses small businesses
thriving
and they have refused to crush the virus
they even admitted
they had no intention of controlling it
much less crisis
crashing it is my hope that with the
vaccine
now with the vaccine that will give
a different perspective across the
threshold to say there is a light at the
end of the tunnel
so that the president and the
administration and the republicans can
say
yes we should follow science in a
shorter period of time than
uh than we've been through already if we
test trace treat wear
masks social distance sanitation
recognizing that uh the hit that this is
taking on to communities of color
if we do what is in the heroes act in
this regard
uh we'll be ready for the vaccine uh to
have a big effect right from the start
and in light of the vaccine
as we have in the heroes act and perhaps
we should do more now
because the vaccine is here it's
imminent
that we should be having the resources
to make sure
that the vaccine is distributed
immediately
equitably so that everyone has access
to it in that regard though for that to
happen
the president must must
must implement the defense production
act
so that those companies those entities
that are used to this
new technology that both um pfizer and
moderna have used
can can undertake making this
uh this vaccine more available
because we're going to need quite a bit
for ourselves
and for the world because unless
everyone is safe as i said
no one is safe so let's hope that let's
hope
it's time for mcconnell's pause to end
uh we have been working on uh the uh
a pr omnibus bill when i thought that
would be a segway into this
let's hope that it is again
uh it is uh curious to see
how they are trying to impede progress
and another misguided act of
irresponsibility
secretary mnuchin has said he would end
many critical emergency
lending initiatives at the end of the
year
now why would they do that
drawing a rare rebuke from the fed
that really speaks out as the fed said
in its statement it would prepare the
full
suite of emergency facilities as
excuse me facilities established during
the coronavirus pandemic
to continue to serve their important
role
as a backstop for our still strained and
vulnerable economy
the fed the fed would prefer the full
suite of emergency facilities
established during the coronavirus
pandemic continue to serve their
important role
as a backdrop for our still strained and
vulnerable economy
it's highly unusual for the fed to
comment
in that manner on something said by the
secretary of the treasury
again why
why because they want to impede the
ability of the next
administration to have everything
available to them the situation could
not be more dire the need for action
could not be more
urgent real meaningful relief is
desperately needed
no surprise to anyone perhaps
except mitch mcconnell the families are
losing lives
and livelihoods the hospitals are
overwhelmed the front line workers
are risking their lives and losing their
jobs the parents are unable to put food
on the table
and keep a roof over their heads 17
million children in america
are food insecure and we couldn't even
get the food
issue into the cares act so we need to
get it
into the legislation now schools are
unable to keep
students and staff safe that could
happen
all we have to do is follow the science
that's
we know how we can open our economy open
our schools safely
but we have to make a decision to follow
science
and good governance again
this week again leader schumer and i
wrote to mcconnell demanding that he
finally come to the table on a
bipartisan bicameral covet relief
as we said in the letter that i
referenced earlier
the dual public health and economic
crisis caused by cova 19
continue to devastate communities across
the country
what is becoming clear to all americans
is that we cannot achieve
real economic recovery until we address
the expanding
public health crisis the time to act
is upon us like never before the
pandemic and the economic recession
will not end without our health
later today dear schumer and i will be
visiting
president-elect biden and vice president
elect harris
we were discussing a lame duck session
the urgency
the urgency of crushing the virus and
easing the pain of this economic crisis
keeping government open as i referenced
early the omnibus bill
we're pleased that our moving forward
moving america forward legislation that
we passed
in the summer and build back better of
joe biden
are so compatible for creating good
paying jobs
including through investments in
infrastructure manufacturing
workforce development clean energy the
list goes on
and on we're very proud okay now
you wonder about this you wonder about
this did you know
did you know that house democrats
got nearly 2 million more votes than
donald trump
i say that because everybody said well
what did
everybody turned out
and it was a great victory a bit a
mandate
the most important thing we did two
years ago was win the house
we won 40 seats 31 of them in trump
districts in the most gerrymandered
voter suppressed political arena you
could name
40 seats 31 in trump districts
i said then it's going to be harder next
time because he'll be on the ballot
and it was and it was and so we will
lose some a few of those seats a couple
in a
hillary district and a few in his
district
but the mat district imagine
nearly two million more votes than
donald trump
and people say well the democrats didn't
turn up no we did
we turned out esco in fact more than 3
million
more than the republicans did but as i
said
again in the most gerrymandered voter
suppressed
political arena with president trump on
the ballot so i congratulate them
for the seats they won i congratulate
him for the
turnout that he he created he got a good
vote
i don't have joe biden up here what's he
up to now 78 million
79 million coming on but i just wanted
to show you how we
relate it to these others so we need
every we need everything
we're family we're a big tent in our
party we're proud of everyone
in it the turnout was across the board
we do believe that our house races in
michigan pennsylvania nevada arizona
georgia have contributed to those
electoral college successes
and across the country to the
almost 79 million votes that joe biden
had
we're very proud of him and kamala
harris
we're proud of him as a unifier for our
country
and we're proud of the big vote that
house democrats
contributed to that success because so
many people were saying well this and
that and they have
no no no we want more
and we will have more and we've already
started that
but i want you to be sure you knew
nearly two million more votes than
donald trump
any questions your uh
oversight committee sent a letter asking
for the head of the gsa to come and
testify
i'm wondering if you could speak to why
they decided to do that now
and for broadly what do you see as the
house's role
in ensuring a smooth transition well i i
don't know that they asked for testify
they wanted a briefing
they asked for a briefing testify is
different that's a hearing
they asked for a a briefing and that is
hopefully before thanksgiving that that
will happen
the uh
you hope that people will have good
faith in the jobs that they have you
want to give them a chance
to get that done it is totally
mystifying
uh that the gsa uh refuses to
make the statement necessary for the
transition to happen in orderly fashion
uh they've been sort of trumpian from
the start from the trump
hotel and all the rest of that way back
when so no surprise that they are
uh following that lead which is most
unfortunate for the country
but what they're saying is explain to us
what your basis is
uh for going down that place yeah and
again
everything was kind of let's let it
see what happen you know let's hope for
the best
but hope that there'd be enough
republicans to say
this is america the people's voices
count and that must be
respected uh so to the extent
it won't be long before we have a uh
a certification the meeting of the
electoral college
december 14th and then here in the house
on january 6th but again it was not to
it was really
trying to be unifying let's take our
time let's give them a chance
and that's why we don't have a hearing
we're just having a briefing
into the second part of that question i
mean do you see an expanded role for the
house and trying to make sure this
process goes smoothly especially as the
president continues to refuse to concede
yes
well i'm not going to show my hand but
nonetheless we're ready we're ready yes
sir
um between the plots against governor
whitmer
and the the two guys who drove up from
virginia
to philadelphia during the county uh do
you or other democrats have concerns
that the longer this goes on
in terms of trump challenging the vote
and other republicans saying he should
exhaust the legal options is it still an
open question
that that raises the prospect for
violence
well we all have to to know that
the president of the united states his
words weigh a ton
they weigh a ton and people hear things
in a way that could encourage
some unfortunate situations
as they have done in the state of
michigan
you would think that there would be on
the part of all republicans
a rejection did you see the array of
agenda items that michiganders had
public execution
have you seen it yeah so you know how
dangerous it is
burning down the capital and not
getting uh shall we say
told that that's not appropriate in our
country
but instead having
god knows how what's his name
atlas oh my god did you see his
statements that
encourage that coming right there from
the
right hand of the president of the
united states
saying you've got to have stirred up in
the streets and the rest of that
so this is a bad behavior but again
let's try to be unifying let's try to be
respectful
there is this element in our country i
don't think
donald trump created it but i think he
fans of flame
and i think that's a dangerous situation
yes sir
madam speaker as you mentioned
businesses are hurting out there and
still there's about 138
million that's allocated in ppp funds
that's
there ready available any any
possibility on releasing some of that
money
well that's up to the administration and
that's why we're saying
um what is this and a plus all the other
money
that mr mnuchin uh has discretion over
that's for bigger business but
nonetheless
as the fed has said so much a part
of our of our economy uh
that that uh uh it's real
that's why that's why i referenced sandy
hook
forget about that's why i referenced
george floyd
let's just move on people are suffering
and if you don't believe in governance
then it's hard that it's easy for you to
say we don't really have to do
all of these things and that's what the
problem is
but i'm optimistic that we will have
bipartisanship
to put something together to go forward
because i do believe that many of our
colleagues
understand what's happening in their
districts and to want to make a
difference
there's just one big obstacle in the way
in the senate
it's mitch mcconnell but the other
obstacle because he
does what uh president trump says and
that's president trump
yes sir yes speaker as far as those
negotiations go right now
who are these active negotiations going
on with is it
house democrats and leader mcconnell
when's the last time you spoke yeah
that's not happening yesterday there was
a meeting
of of the um staff of the four
corners that would be the house and
senate democratic republican leaders
the the anticipation was that it was
really about
the uh the omnibus remember we have to
have an omnibus bill we must keep
government open that's a
very important responsibility during the
lame duck
uh we don't want another continuing
resolution i don't think they do
either so we have an expression
yesterday was
for the the staffs to deal with what we
call
the ash and trash you know just some of
the
things that are not up here but need to
be
resolved so that we can move forward and
that hopefully we would have been able
to begin
a path to the covet that didn't happen
but hopefully it will
excuse me now these were the four
leaders
four leaders yes ma'am secretary mnuchin
uh
said this morning that he is meeting
with uh leader mccarthy and leader
mcconnell later today to talk about a
stimulus
deal for coverage um do you have any
plans to talk to him upcoming
well he said in his comments that they
would be uh
reaching out but we're asking to come
back to this we've been sitting at the
table
for six months plus a week
waiting for them to come back the
obstacles have been
they do not want to honor our heroes our
our state and local workers our health
care workers
our teachers our teachers our teachers
our first responders our police and fire
our transportation sanitation food
workers who make our existence
possible they're saying they don't want
to do that
and in fact many of those workers are
laid off they have risked their lives to
save lives
and now they must lose their jobs many
over a million of them have
the other part of that is that the
fiscal
soundness of our state and local
governments is important to the fiscal
soundness of our country
so it doesn't make any sense uh in terms
of
meeting the needs of people honoring the
work of our heroes
and again the sound of our economy so
we'll we have to get something done
and again they have been resistant on
many of the things
that we consider priorities but
everybody knows people are hungry people
are fearing eviction
people need the uh the cares act
provisions to be extended that address
unemployment in shorts and the rest
i won't go into how they comment on all
of that
but the main thing that they have
the two main things honor our heroes
so that the states and local governments
can meet the needs
that we talked about hospitalizations
and all the rest it's corona
virus-centric
as well as revenue loss because of
shutdown
and but this is the most mystifying
to me and the most unscientific
they will not decide to crush the virus
my hope is the vaccine will say okay
there's a path so let's stop the
spread of it while we manufacture
more and distribute more of it that's
right do you think you'll hear from the
secretary before the end of the day
why no condemnation of the violence
against trump supporters last weekend